[Music]
well back here at home our other top
story no bail for a clark county elected
official facing a murder charge in the
death of the las vegas journalist jeff
gearman robert thales made his first
court appearance today it's been a
chaotic story since it all began last
weekend victoria saha gives us a recap
ever since jeff gearman was found
stabbed to death outside his home
saturday morning police have been urging
for the public's help to find his killer
after releasing new video of the suspect
and a potential car earlier in the week
by wednesday telus was the prime suspect
wednesday morning police issued a search
warrant at telus's house questioning him
at metro and they confiscated potential
evidence including his car and clothing
hours later telus returned home in a
white jumpsuit and refused to comment
then as police were trying to contact
him there was no answer at the door
sources tell our 8 news now
investigators telus was taken into
custody after he was taken to the
hospital with non-life-threatening
self-inflicted wounds our 8 news now
cameras were there as he was wheeled in
victoria saha 8 news now